[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you tapped into the group chat live in
the bluetooth report app presented by
fanduel today's show is brought to you
by the alphabet
as in we hit every button on our
keyboards in the group chat reacting to
damian lillard and steph curry going
off last night my name is cathy richards
she is our betting expert and
liable to say anything in front of a hot
microphone like draymond green
that is kelly stewart and waving the
flag for the bay area
is mr greg ivory welcome uh each week
in our chuck versus america segment you
guys pick the prop beds
and we go head to head with the hall of
famer charles barkley
america the gambling gods answered a
prayer
for hashtag free barkley and chuck
got a w last week that tenney was back
he chose to ride with houston
to be the first team to score 10 points
and it hit so let's please
update the standings america we took
happy cabbie cabbie
yeah in my defense they're actually in
our defense yes
we were on the same side as chuck so i
don't want to have that
that one loss on my record i'm sorry
that the audience chose wrong i don't
think that's fair
the audience did i mean we have to ride
with america but listen we're still
three games up on chuck
he's at five and four we're at eight and
one so we got to continue to get it
um g-money hoodies for good vibes
cause we need some good vibes today
let's go let's start the show off
right if you guys are new to the show
and don't know about the handy-dandy
ipad let me introduce you this is your
best friend the handy dandy ipad because
this
is where i give away the hoodies cabbie
i am in the comments
i got finn sanity five he got the
giannis
he got the honest gift flex and flexing
very hard
uh shouts out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie j321
poses a question says can i get a hoodie
guess what
yes you can get a little you're walking
away with a hoodie
uh i got one more cabbie i got one more
one more okay
los los cisco los cisco says lebron
triple double no a d and no
kd for the nets he's locking in the
lebron triple double i wonder
what the value that is uh i love fanduel
but uh
that's gotta be that's gotta be around
plus 300 plus 400 on fanduel love that
yo shout out to him yeah so so tonight
in our chuck versus america bet
it's a special one because we are going
back to our to br betting's
custom fanduel prop the three by two
very simply is will there be two
three-pointers made
in the first three minutes of the game
the three bites it's america's favorite
bet
so we're rocking with the three by two
um last week
we locked in the philly versus portland
game and here's how it played out
look at da i mean it's always game time
isn't it g money whatever that guy
is airports gyms anything
shout out to gary trent jr bang it only
took 45 seconds
uh for the three by two it hit last week
so we love that
and we hope we get some of that today
because we asked you on social on
twitter
will there be a 3x2 in tonight's
brooklyn
and la game may we please see the
twitter poll
it is an emphatic yes 83 percent of the
vote
is rocking with the yes brooklyn's got
three talented shooters
from range in the starting lineup
tonight so not a bad pick
greg how confident is the audience in
the comments
that tonight's three by two is the cash
cabbie how confident is the audience
yeah
let me ask them audience how confident
are you guys
into three in the three by two today let
me help you guys
just say yes because we are writing make
sure you guys come on over
to the br instagram uh live be our
betting instagram live
we will be riding the three by two we'll
be on the live looking for taste
giveaway t-shirts
but uh we're riding cabbie we are riding
you guys just get throw gifts in the
comments throw gifts throw a bunch of
yes gifts
throw it yes in the comments just say
yes make it creative i'm giving away
hoodies kelly
what is your take are you riding with us
or are you faded
well we already know we've talked about
how this is really tough to handicap
and i said hey i'm gonna ride this till
it dies it died and then it
came back like the undertaker gif and
we've been crushing ever since so
look i'm gonna ride i do have my
concerns because
greg you and i talked about pre-show how
much this total has dropped from the
opening and that kind of scares me like
hey
we know that the nets heavily lean
towards the over we know that the lakers
heavily lean towards the under i wanted
to get involved in under i was too late
to the party
which scares me about the scoring right
out of the gate here
if it is an under type game but i do
like the first half over i think we are
going to see some
big time scoring out of the gate maybe
things start to cool off there
in the second half it gets really close
around the total but i like yes
so i am riding with you guys last week
kelly and i were on no with the rockets
today we are rocking with the yes
with the brooklyn nets or whomever i
mean brooklyn's got three
shooters that shoot better than 40
percent from rage
kyrie joe harris james harden so one of
those two
three dudes hits one on the other side
all you need is like a marcosol
or a kcp to light it up from downtown
and we're booking it so
i'm rocking with yes america 83 of you
guys on twitter
love the yes g-money how is the audience
in the comments reacting are they riding
with us
tonight in the brooklyn and la game
cabbie there's a gift party
in there oh yeah there's unwrap them
baby
in the comments uh i'm seeing a bunch of
sunsets shout out to
all everybody with the sunsets my uh
zach
zach waltzman shouts out to you he said
sunset locks but i'm also seeing a bunch
of yeses
i'm seeing a bunch of yeses ak-47 big
blue shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie uh d
geek deep geek
tapped if you don't have a hoodie this
season
you you might be walking away with one
right now let's get to that
shout out to you d geek uh u
r i u r i m e c h y i'm not even gonna
try to pronounce that but shout out to
you for the gift you're walking away
with a hoodie he got he got somebody
doing the running man cabbie doing the
running man
that's what we're gonna be doing that is
what we're gonna be doing
after we cash this bet and it's plus
money
kelly you like value let's go
ak-47 big blue is that andre kirilenko
i don't know if that that guy might be a
little bit before your time g money but
salute to andre kirilenko the inventor
of the whole position oh
that is anyway so america
tune in to inside the nba on tnt to find
out if charles barkley is riding with us
yes there's gonna be uh yes the three by
two will hit
or no just find out and uh and make sure
to
tap in with fanduel or type in with us
on our br socials
to get the link to the 3x2 offered by
our friends at fanduel
once james harden was traded to brooklyn
it was only a matter of time before that
new big three would become one of the
betting favorites
to win an nba championship g-money
jumped on the bandwagon
right away but kelly was a little bit
more skeptical take a
season i look brooklyn was the one i
thought that they were going to be the
team to pull it out
even without james harden now they got
james harden
that i mean that just stamps it like
hold on
oh great
be above them in the eastern conference
book it
three minutes i'm gonna go ahead and we
can we can side bet that way
miami and philly let's we can side bet
that kelly 500
if you want to another 500
whoo you guys got to start another one
bitcoin right now let's go now how do
you feel about seeing that clip
a month later the nets are sitting in
second place i am
fine we are cruising the nets are not
going to win at all don't you worry
i have no worries in the world this team
is still i understand they got to ride
the wave
they're going to make it deep into the
playoffs they're not one in the east
sorry
greg right now they're riding oh i just
want to clarify
i just want to clarify the bet is not
the one in the east the bet is them
finishing
i think it's top three top three in the
east
i heard that two two i heard that too
yeah so
yeah you know we got to clarify bets
around here but yeah kelly
uh you know my vamo actually you can
cash out you can cash out right now for
a 4.95 i'll let you pass out right now
if you want to
love the cash
nets are riding a four game windshield
actually let's take a look at the
updated odds on the nba futures
uh presented by fanduel the odds to win
the 2021 nba championship
lakers still holding down the top spot
at plus
250 brooklyn's right there plus 400 as
we go
it's interesting the utah jazz plus 1100
best team in the nba getting very little
respect
um g money has the audience changed
its mind about riding with the
you know the lakers to win the nba
finals
cabbie uh you know what let me ask them
i need everybody in the audience
everybody in the comments
handy dandy's right here everybody in
the comments i'm talking to you guys
uh i need you guys to tell me who's
the favorite to win the championship
who's winning it all
get in the comments let me know i'm
giving away hoodies kelly
who are you thinking are you switching
it up are you staying
loyal to who you played last time what
are you doing kelly
i didn't like the nuggets to come out of
the west i thought that they were going
to have
a much more cohesive team similar to the
one we saw in the bubble
they're just not gelling right now nor
do they want to play defense they have
some moments of greatness
and then they fall flat on their faces
the next game what can i say they're
just not that complete of a team you
know who is a very complete team and
cabbie just said they're getting no
respect well they got my respect
i feel like they've covered 187 games in
a row utah jazz
don't step in front of that train just
yet i do think that they will come back
a little bit down to earth i think we
can find them
better value later on but at 11 to 1
right now
i'm gonna pull out a little mikey locks
and do a little sprinkle dingle
i you know what i the you know
everybody's on everybody loves
the la lakers and lebron is having an
mvp
uh type of season but the other team
that plays at staples center also
getting no love and that's the la
clippers they have two players
that are having 50 40 90 seasons and
listen maybe they're one maybe they're
one piece away maybe there's a trade
coming the trade deadlines in about
three weeks
they add another piece they could be
getting
they could go deep and nobody's talking
about the clippers kel's i wanted to ask
you there plus 500
on on fanduel is that enough value for
you
pers for your personal taste to lock in
uh
one of these long shots on a futures
no 501 cabs just isn't really that
enticing to me and honestly
when you told me the jazz were 11-1 that
is why i did jump in
i would have thought prior to the show
if you said kelly what do you think the
jazz are i would have said seven
eight to one but you're right they're
not getting respect from the book makers
so just remember the true odds aren't
always what you see on the board guys
the lakers are priced because we're
getting tons of lakers money
the clippers are priced because we're
getting tons of clippers money the jazz
not getting a ton of love right now the
nets getting way too much love i still
cannot wait
to take some of greg's money
uh speaking of your speaking of your
money is your army
are any of your army with you on the
brooklyn nets pick to win the nba
championship
cabbie the comments are all
over the place to be honest i'm giving
away hoodies just for takes
i see a lot of utah jazz kelly you have
a lot of backers here
we got comcad concat shout out to you
you're walking away with hoodie
uh concat again he's rocking with the
jazz ritchie 21 is rocking with the jazz
enderman is rocking with the jazz uh
big b 69 is rocking with the jazz
kelly kelly you got you got a lot of
people here
from following you but hold on kelly i
mean hold on kelly and cabby
i got mg go blue rocking with the nets
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie
i have uh h1ch rocking with the next all
right gabby i'm done
whoever i just said you're walking away
but as you can see cabbie
the comments are all over the place
there's also lakers in there
i saw uh i even saw i even see uh
kelly's team the denver nuggets i even
saw them in there so they're all over
the place in the comments
keep filling them up with uh gifts and i
might give you a hoodie well listen with
anthony davis's
continued struggles with injuries it
feels like
the the race is a little bit more wide
open this season so who knows
one of those are going to hit and i
guess we'll find out in uh
june before the 3x2 we had the furboo
salute to mikey lox the first basket
is one of our favorite quick hitters and
it's returning tonight
so the question is who's gonna score the
first bucket of the brooklyn nets
and the lakers game let's take a look at
uh the latest odds
braun at the top as per usual plus 430.
this one is juicy because
as you work work your way a little bit
further down the list joe harris plus
850 deandre jordan maybe he catches a
lob at the rim
for plus a thousand bruce bowen at plus
1400
it's it's pretty wide open and fanduel
is offering
first basket insurance for tonight's
brooklyn and that and
la game so if your first basket bet
doesn't hit
but your player scores 25 points or more
fanduel will refund your first basket
bet up to 25 bucks each game
however you have to opt in so make sure
you check out
fanduel beforehand so you gotta opt in
to get this first
basket insurance bet so g-money the
action starts
right from tip-off so many options for
first basket
who have you decided to rock with
cabbie yes should i hop in the comments
right now
you can because i yeah let me let me ask
them let me let me tee it up let me ask
them first
so look it guys in the comments guys and
girls and
everybody in the comments let me know
who's gonna have the first bucket today
that's all you have to do let me know
whether if it's a gif
type it in uh text it in i don't know
send it send it in let me know who we're
riding with and uh
we're gonna ride kelly who are you
leading who do you think the audience
should be leaning
towards look the obvious are at the top
lebron
hardin kyrie those are not fun i like to
look
down the list because i feel like it's
like a mikey locks bet anyway you're
throwing darts
so let's go through a scenario right and
this is how you're going to decide on
your bet okay
lakers are at home they maybe win the
tip get a turnover
no k.d tonight for the nets who's going
to step up in his absence maybe we see a
little joe harris
from the outside i don't know this is
tough i went back and forth i was like
maybe kcp will step up with no anthony
davis
so i picked somebody in the middle plus
8 50. i took joe harris i think he's got
an outside shot to do it
because again this is just such a tough
thing it's really almost impossible to
handicap
so many things come into play right
after the tip but at plus 850 i thought
why not i'll do a mikey lock start
that's a solid pick that's what's uh and
i like your your reasoning there
brooklyn's coming into the game
on a four-game win streak they're pretty
hot excellent game against phoenix
kyrie returns tonight and kyrie he's the
shooting guard i think he gets it
started for brooklyn
whether it's a a step not a stepping
maybe it's a turnaround jay or a
three-pointer i think kyrie
is the one to hit the first bucket
tonight
gee who is who does the audience like
for first basket
we'll see cabbie i see a whole bunch of
names
i got uh eddie on the go he got the
dennis schruter gift going i got joe
harris here
i got uh a brand statter a brand statter
is rocking with kyrie uh jay sanchez 89
is rocking with kyrie
they're rocking with you cabbie uh i see
joe harris kelly they
they they're riding with you today kelly
uh
grace24 joey buckets joey buckets joey
buckets
i got hap h happily
happy h-a-p-w-i they're rocking with
joe they're rocking with joey uh one
more cabbie one more
the comments are moving today the
comments are moving
max max i cry more 69
says kyrie irving he's rocking with
kyrie
i saw they're just writing what you guys
are saying the user handles are
hilarious this week
is this the first show we're like on
multiple bets that kelly's getting loved
kelly's getting some follows from the
comments
utah jazz a bunch of commenting and then
and then
joe harris even you
i mean both of you guys are getting love
in the comments they're showing
that love today it's a turning point in
the season
they're showing mad love today uh
yeah but i mean i i if if i was to
choose someone i
i would say lebron why not john's gonna
have a big game today
somebody's probably gonna have right
favorites bro you you like it's
surprising that you're not a cowboys fan
a yankees fan
you know friggin flakers and so
let's you just i'm okay anyway let's
move on let's move on okay get out
i'm not trying to throw shade at you g
money all i'm saying is
the front runners this is a tiny bit
this is
just enough shade to keep me from
getting burnt
uh lock in fanduel to choose your guy to
score the first bucket of tonight's
brooklyn versus l.a game and as always
send us your video
videos if the furboo hits the first
bucket hits
we want to see some celebrations we want
to see some vibes sunsets or whatever
um listen if our team if our group chat
was a baseball team
greg ivory would be moving down the
batting over order
because right now he's mired in an 0-8
slump
when it comes to picking a successful
five-legged
single game parlay we earlier in the
show there was a 500
bed thrown out there about the brooklyn
nets there is still
a standing 500 bet that greg will not
correctly choose a five-legged single
game barley
500 bet with kelly uh and today g
money um actually last week you were
super close let's take a look at uh last
week would you
would you like to address last week
cabbie how greg
tried to take a parlay that should be
22-1
at the minimum to three to one
and joel embiid came in for me i sent
kathy a late-night text and said wow
i can't believe he lost that that is
called karma
well dude you know what's going on hold
on
you know what's going on between cabbies
intro
and kelly's take on my ticket there's a
lot of bad vibes going on a lot of bad
vibes i need the comments
to turn this thing around i need sunsets
in the comments right now
let's turn these vibes into good vibes
because we have to set the tone
we have to set the tone for this five
game parlay you
you guys threw a bunch of stones to
start off let's set the vibes come on
comments
sunset okay okay listen we're gonna
quiet the stadium
we're gonna leave it nice and quiet for
you g money to step into the batter's
box
and take another swing at a single leg
or a single game parlay have at it my
friend good luck
y'all ready y'all ready you're right all
right here we go slinkers let's get
starting it off
starting it off we got montrez harrell
to score over 10 points
trash go get 10 that's all we need baby
for you to just go get 10.
you can see that happening very easily
moving right along
moving right along to joe harris
joe yes kelly he was one of your guys
one of the guys you chose today joe
harris going
over 13 and a half points
joe go get some buckets he showed up
last game cabbie
i don't know if you know but he showed
up he was the second option no katie
no kyrie he had to show up and joe
delivered go get some buckets today joe
why not
moving on cabbie james harden
he had a game last game he hit the heat
the game winning three
little step back no kd
i see james having a game tonight as
well
i'm gonna go over three and a half made
threes cabbie we're going to see a lot
of tween tween
as he step back pops from james i can
see it i can see it already
so i'm rocking with over three and a
half three points made
moving right along moving right along
kyrie irving he's playing against lebron
james
the game is in los angeles he did not
play
the last game it's gonna be semi-fresh
semi-fresh
kyrie is gonna ball he's gonna ball
today i'm gonna rock with the over
27 and a half points for kyrie uh kyrie
go be you uncle drew go get those
buckets and last but not least last but
not least
i said he was gonna get the first bucket
but i also think that he's gonna ball
today he's gonna absolutely ball no
a.d no a.d lebron is gonna have to serve
today
i got lebron going over 30 and a half
points facing kyrie
you know when he you know they have that
little uh rivalry you know
big brother little brother thank you how
it went low yeah big brother little
brother a little robbery so you know
i see brian uh putting his foot down
just a little bit in tonight's game and
uh
running up that point running up those
points g-money i'm a little
like let's say kyrie has has lower back
stiffness
i know he's going to be excited to play
in hollywood and play against his former
big brother
or his big brother but i i'm the the co
it's the kyrie pick like i don't know
sometimes my guy is lighting it up
sometimes he's a little inconsistent
so that one's gonna be i think it's
gonna be the hardest leg it's the kyrie
over
27 and a half points kel's what do you
think cabbie there's a lot of
there's a lot of sunsets in the comments
for a reason right now goodbye
thank you of course there is greg you
picked every single over
i have my i have my uh my issues here
harden over
three and a half threes it's kind of
dicey i understand
no kd he should get fed the ball a lot
sweet it means if you want him to make
four threes he better shoot
the ball at least 12 times from
three-point land
and lebron you're always paying a
premium for my dude named lebron
i don't love that i could see him
landing on 28 points
and not just setting your ticket on fire
which i will get some
sick satisfaction out of just like i did
last thursday night
how does it how does the audience feel
who do you tap in with
to build this part of it and how does
the audience feel about this ticket
today and also
what's the value actually let's let's
yeah let's pull up the ticket let's pull
up the ticket the audience is loving i
mean i see a whole bunch of vibes oh
weird
another five teamer that's not even what
a normal five teamer plays
i'm gonna educate everybody at home a
five teamer if you walk up
and pick five nba sides and put on a
five team pace 22 to one
22 to one these are just these are just
really unacceptable that's
that's that's 18 that's almost there
kelly oh
this is not three to one again it's
almost there
it's a cool little hey can we pull it
back up one more time because i gotta uh
show them what they be what they're
gonna be walking away with could we pull
it back up one more time
there it is 900 right there 900
kelly that's not a hundred that's 900
off of 50 thank you very much uh
cabbie can i give away some uh can i
give away some hoodies absolutely
yeah generosity for the vibes my dude
i'm thank you thanks see cabbie you're
starting to get it
coming right i'm starting to get the box
you're starting to get the vibes
handy dandy's back on my hand i'm in the
comments giving away
hoodies here we go i see uh a brand
statter a brand statter
he's rocking he sees as he said sunsets
i see a lot of sunsets
uh here we go df1234
is riding with the parlay shouts out to
udf you're walking away with a hoodie uh
prince atg he said kelly that was a
little rude of you to talk about the
king like that
with 28 points i agree because the king
king lebron is going to ball today he is
going to ball
shout out to you prince you're walking
away with a hoodie uh deep geek overs
only please
of course you should be called overs
only please that's shout out
more winners we just need all the overs
forever and ever and ever
shout out to you dick hey whatever gets
it done
whatever gets it done uh here we go i i
see more sunsets cabbie so i'm just
going to start giving them away okay
shout out to anymore we gotta we gotta
break grace and 24.
grace j three two one sunsets all right
that's it cabbie says we gotta go
d-e-t clark you're also walking away
with a hoodie
thank you so much everybody you're good
thank you so much
for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today
get the insurance on the first bucket
the furboo
uh offered by fanduel get on ig live and
ride with g money tonight and
three by two in that next and lakers
game and if you scroll back far enough
in your own group chats
you'll find the receipts for side vets
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
my name is kathy richards we are leaving
the group chat
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you